und hier in berlin machen mitarbeiter
der berliner stadtreinigung heute morgen
am alexanderplatz einen grausamen fund
eine tödlich verletzte person am fuß des
fernsehturms
bild reporterin isabel van kuche ist
weiterhin für uns am alexanderplatz vor
ort isabell war
ja ich höre gerade wir schauen uns das
ganze noch mal an was genau passiert
heute morgen hier der bericht
berliner alexanderplatz 6 uhr morgens
ein toter mann liegt blutüberströmt auf
dem boden mitarbeiter der berliner
stadtreinigung finden die leiche und das
hier mitten in der stadt an dem wasser
treppen am fuße des fernsehturms was ist
mit ihm passiert die polizei geht von
einem gewaltverbrechen aus nach ihrem
kenntnisstand wurde heute früh gegen 26
hier am alexanderplatz ein mann mit
tödlichen verletzungen aufgefunden
sowohl die verletzungen als auch die
auffindesituation deuten aktuell auf ein
tötungsdelikt hin
der tatort ist großräumig abgesperrt die
berliner mordkommission hat die
ermittlungen übernommen
wer hat sich heute morgen gegen 6 uhr
auf dem berliner alexanderplatz
aufgehalten und die tat womöglich
gesehen hinweise bitte an die berliner
polizei unter 030 4664 0 oder jede
andere polizeidienststelle
so jetzt ist sie aber da isabelle
pfannkuche unserem bild reporterin
isabel wir haben erst im laufe des
vormittags sind wir dachten es handelt
sich hierbei um eine weibliche person um
ein weibliches opfer jetzt ist aber klar
die leiche ist ein mann
genau es handelt sich dabei um einen
mann es ist wenn man so will wirklich
ein sehr makaberer ort für einen mord
denn wir haben hier direkt im
fernsehturm die ausstellung körperwelten
die ja auch für tote körper bekannt ist
und hier fand eben dieser mord statt es
ist wirklich ein grausamer mord die
leiche wurde jetzt abtransportiert vor
so circa zehn minuten
und die wollen jetzt in sie wollen jetzt
anfangen die leiche richtig zu
obduzieren der das ist ja immer noch
nicht klar um welche person es sich
handelt es ist zwar klar es ist ein mann
aber die leiche wurde noch nicht
identifiziert und die polizei hofft dass
am abend das alter von der person schon
mal fest steht dieser contest dort vor
ort auch ja mit einem möglichen zeugen
sprechen was weißt du alles genau über
diese grausamen stunden die frühen
morgenstunden hier in der hauptstadt am
alex
genau ein zeuge hat uns vorhin
angesprochen er ist heute morgen vom
feiern zurückgekehrt war hier im
nikolaiviertel unterwegs und ist so um
viertel vor sechs hier lang gelaufen hat
einen streit beobachtet dabei soll auch
eine person höher aufgerufen haben aber
er hat ist dann weitergegangen hat sich
auch nichts dabei gedacht
und ja es ist bekannt dass es sich eben
um ein streitgespräch gehandelt haben
soll insgesamt ist die gegend hier auch
dafür bekannt dass sehr viele obdachlose
hier sind und auch oft hier alkohol
getrunken wird aber worum es sich genau
handelt weiß man eben der noch noch
nicht isabel auch spürhunde sind bei dir
im einsatz was sollen die bringen
von den spürhunden
habe ich bisher hier noch nichts gesehen
aber natürlich müssen die spuren
gesichert werden man weiß ja momentan
noch nichts von einem täter also wer der
täter sein könnte sie haben auch noch
keinen tatverdächtigen festgenommen und
dementsprechend müssen natürlich alle
spuren gesichert werden und muss einem
nachgegangen werden was hier zu finden
ist vielen dank isabel van kuchen für
diese ersten informationen ja ein
beliebtes viertel dort am alexanderplatz
also wir hoffen natürlich dass sich
dieser mord diese tat schnell aufklären
lässt vielen dank
[Musik]